tracking teachers in trouble should they
remain in the classroom while they're
being investigated thanks for joining us
at six i'm denise valdez and i'm brian
loftis the eight news now i-team
uncovering how school staff can simply
move to another district despite serious
allegations the i-team's vanessa murphy
here with a follow-up to a story she
first broke friday
denise and brian it can be difficult for
schools to really vet who they hire to
work with children it takes a lot for a
teaching license to be revoked and in
this case legacy traditional schools
which fired the teachers has a reference
policy that only provides dates of
employment and title for former
employees so when other schools are
calling for a reference check they
wouldn't be informed the teachers were
fired and being investigated
the proof is evident and the presumption
is great
that these crimes were committed judge
susan balcom saying the allegations
against victoria welling christopher
olmsted and andrea fuentes soto are so
egregious they should be in jail they're
accused of taking part in a scheme to
steal nearly 154 thousand dollars of
covid 19 relief funding set aside for
school projects i am victoria welling
was the principal at legacy traditional
school southwest campus olmsted and
fuentes soto were teachers there a
spokesman for the charter school says
four employees including the three
defendants were fired that was late last
year and since then while they were
being investigated and before they were
charged in july the 8 news now i-team
has learned welling and olmsted took new
jobs to continue to work with children a
spokesman for york county south carolina
schools says olmsted was hired in
january to teach middle school the
i-team has learned welling had been
hired by the clark county school
district to start working as an
assistant principal at a-tech in july
however a spokesman says welling
informed the district she would not take
the position within the last week
both york and ccsd say background checks
were done and both candidates passed
their felony cases in las vegas justice
court wouldn't show up the arrest
warrants were recently issued and they
haven't been convicted all three have
active teaching licenses in the state of
nevada it appears olmsted does not have
an active teaching license in south
carolina and the spokesman says his
employment for the next school year is
pending based on the district receiving
the license from the department of ed
there
welling was taken into custody thursday
she posted bond and was released friday
as of tuesday evening olmsted and
fuentes soto remain in jail the bond for
all three the exact same amount which
police say was stolen not only to
maintain the safety of the community but
to ensure your appearance in court
christopher olmstead was also a summer
employee at the ymca here in southern
nevada a spokeswoman says he didn't have
access to money but the y and olmstead
have quote severed their relationship